des smartphones gentes détonne samsung
apple chez ont mis au pot je les connais
presque tous il ya une marque qui est
assez peu connu en france et qui
pourtant est leader en chine c'est vivo
vivo ça vous dit peut-être quelque chose
on a vu son nom sur les panneaux
publicitaires en bord de terrain lors
lauro 2020 d'ailleurs ça sera la même
chose pour la coupe du monde au qatar
mais vive hausse et une boîte qui
innovent énormément ils sont à l'origine
du capteur d'empreintes digitales sous
l'écran de la caméra pop up et de la
caméra guillemoles dans un smartphone
soyons clairs le vivent au 23 n'est pas
du tout le smartphone le plus innovant
de la marque mais ils ont mis un petit
quelque chose de différent à commencer
par le fait qu'ils changent de couleur à
la lumière du soleil d'ailleurs la
marque promet un bon smartphone avec une
double caméra celle fille et un double
flash led le tout à 529 euros je vous
emmène aujourd'hui en balade pour voir
s'ils vivent au v 23 tient ses promesses
[Musique]
le téléphone qui changent de couleur ça
c'est en tout cas c'est marrant café de
vivo les jaunes mais dès que je lui
mettrais l'enjeu même mes doigts comme
ça on verra la marque dès que j'ai le
sortir après impôts plein soleil il est
jeune il est jeune il est jaune et il va
devenir vert et lorsque je l'admets
droite à la marque qui va paraître tu
vois voilà il était jaune comme ça il
est devenu vert comme ça alors il va
devoir devenir jaune comme ça en 10 15
minutes et en fait il réagit au soleil
et c'est assez marrant pourquoi parce
qu'en fait à toutes les marques de
smartphones qu'ils viennent un peu
uniforme aujourd'hui et l'idée
d'apporter un truc un peu différent
comme ça je trouve ça marrant alors
c'est du marketing c'est pas le truc qui
va faire qu'on va venir acheter ce
smartphone mais ce qui est super
intéressant est ce qu'on voit est ce que
ça montre c'est que les marques à
cherche vraiment à se différencier en
essayant de proposer quelque chose de
différent est ce que ce smartphone pour
autant garder la ce a complètement
disparu maintenant il ya plus d'une
seule couleur et latin côté bleu plus
foncé et là tu as un côté un peu vert ça
c'est marrant est ce que ça suffit à
venir est acheté ce smartphone je suis
pas convaincu il a d'autres trucs
intéressants mais reconnaît quand même
assez rigolo non c'est le lézard alors
quelles promesses ils nous font avec ce
vivo avait 23 caméras 50 mégapixels à
l'avant il ya la double ok caméra de 64
mégapixels à l'arrière caméra du ultra
grand-angle 100 5 mégapixels le 50
mégapixels pour la caméra quand on
gueule avant double flash et il met
vraiment paquet là-dessus créer une
ambiance avec le changement de couleur
changements de température pardon au
niveau des leds selphy nuit sous les
projecteurs c'est un smartphone red hill
le matin pour bloguer c'est vraiment un
smartphone qui a été créée dans l'esprit
du blog on va venir utiliser les caméras
de celle ci on a le retour moniteur est
ce qu'au final ce vivo et 23 c'est
vraiment le smartphone qui vous faut 1
529 euros pour venir lober c'est ce
qu'on me rallie tout de suite
avec le smartphone c'est effectivement
que ce filet comme ça ce film est comme
ça à se fier de ce film est comme ça
voyez directement l'empêchant 4 4
anticipé dans quatre cas 60 mais le truc
est vraiment intéressant c'est de se
filmer dans l'autre sens en vertical en
mode cloud donc là je monte quand même
sur la caméra arrière et je peux passer
sur la caméra avant et là sur la caméra
avant alors le circuit où le voit tout
de suite là c'est qu'il ya aucune
stabilisation ce qui veut dire que ça
bouge si je veux que ce soit stabilisée
j'ai un truc comme ça alors moi je veux
sympa larache la gare déposé là comme ça
dans mon vélo et là s'est stabilisé sa
bouche mais ça c'est un petit peu j'ai
remarqué sur ce smartphone et que je
trouve un peu relou c'est qu'en fait il
n'y a aucune stabilisation nulle part
sur un capteur et c'est un peu le
problème parce que si comme moi vous
avez un peu la bougeotte tout de suite
ça va être un peu un mythe on va
retourner un plat je suis en mode blog
c'est vraiment comme ça qu'on veut venir
l'utiliser voyez je prends la main je te
crois demain mais parce que moi j'ai un
tremblement essentiel et du coup là me
mettre dans cette rue il n'ya jamais
personne ici
je suis vraiment peinard comme ça je les
pose et je suis en ambiance blog alors
là je vous montre je marque je peux
venir vous mais sans la caméra de
cellfish peut monter en quoi en x 2
watts je peux descendre passé en x 1c
assez smooth et après il ya plein de
petites fonctionnalités qui seront assez
marrant tu vas voir le double vue avec
ma caméra de celle fille et ma caméra
derrière alors la voyez je les en
rondelles avoir carré mais se met des
petits coeurs voilà comme ça si vous
voulez mettre quelqu'un dedans avec un
petit cadeau vous pouvez regarder par
exemple à mon p'tit vélo avec un petit
coeur bat je peux voilà totalement
versée avec un petit hurle dans comme ça
je vous prends avec beaucoup d'amour
pour le dual view je sais pas si en
grand intérêt mais bon en tout cas et
c'est assez rigolo mais de l'amour mais
des petits coeurs partout comme ça mais
les petits coeurs
[Musique]
vous faites des vélos qui freine les
garçons ça fait pas ça c'est vachement
bien plus si on veut sert mal pas mal
aussi vraiment anticiper et à la fin on
descend et on sait que
c'est une vraie galère vraiment ici non
[Musique]
avant de vous montrer ce qu'on peut
faire la nuit en mode blog ici il ya une
force une idée qui est extrêmement
intéressante et très importante c'est ce
qui se passe ici je pas si vous le voyez
vous avez en fait un double flash led et
en fait vous venez activer votre double
flash led vous venez ici regardez vous
avez spot désactiver automatique bon là
il y en a pas trop besoin ou alors vous
mettez ce qu'on appellera le mode spot
et là ça vous lance le double flash led
et ça peut paraître tout bête mais
regardez sa femme petit renfort alors là
il ya les lumières les éteindre garder
parce que j'aime bien la lumière et que
je viens comme ça eh ben mine de rien là
tout de suite on ne voit pas et pas
beaucoup de lumière et là j'ai quand
même cette petite lumière qui est là
alors bon c'est qu'un petit renfort mais
malgré tout ce truc est intéressant et
en plus de ça on peut venir changer la
température de couleur toujours dans vos
paramètres vous appuyer là vous appuyez
ici sur ce mode activé et là vous
choisissez vous avez blanc froid vous
avez jaune chaleureux carrément alors
vous passez au milieu par défaut vous
avez du blanc vous avez du jaune ça va
dépendre effectivement de ce que vous
voulez par rapport à votre température
de couleur et moi tout ça pas mal
franchement rigolo
[Musique]
e
le truc qui est intéressant c'est
lorsque vous filmez la nuit sauf que là
tu es ben c'est la nuit alors je peux me
mettre à l'abri mais on voit pas grand
chose d'où l'intérêt du double flash led
qu'il lit et m'a fait son taf de flash
led alors regardez est-ce qu'on va
vraiment bien avec ce truc faut vraiment
que je sois devant en fait je pense que
ce truc là ça marche on tire en force
mais si je fais comme ça c'est pas où
est est ce que je peux alors j'en ai je
peux modifier donc là je suis par défaut
donc là j'ai le jeu passe sur le plus
chaud c'est très très chaud j'ai
l'impression que ça marche quand même
pas trop mal comme ça on voit un peu
mieux si je viens modifier la wah wah
moi mais c'est pas mal et si jamais les
deux en même temps parce que ça marche
mieux comme ça donc non c'est pas mal
alors après je suis sur la caméra de
cette fille c'est pas forcément le genre
les qualités d'homme mais malgré tout ça
reste très bruitée sur la peau donc si
marrant
à prendre comme ça ça reste pas
stabilisé donc c'est pas ou fait mais en
petit renfort lorsqu'on commence à
manquer on peut faire quelque chose là
il ya vraiment décidément passé lumière
met sur un petit renfort pourquoi pas
sinon vous faites avec la caméra que
derrière comme ça là et je pense que
c'est là où ça fera un peu mieux je
prends je tourne le film comme ça
et c'est peut-être là où je vais même
avoir le meilleur résultat
m
[Musique]
on va regarder ce que raconte un peu ses
fichiers vidéo voir ci sont plutôt de
bonne qualité ou pas de bonne qualité on
se jette un petit coup d'oeil ensemble
vous les avez déjà vu nous on va les
débris fait là on va les regarder
ensemble alors là ce qu'on voit tout de
suite rapidement c'est le même problème
qu on avait déjà vu c'est à dire un
problème de stabilisation alors c'est
pas un problème c'est un choix qu'a fait
la marque en fait ici en étant
absolument aucune stabilisation et
fatalement bah voilà ça ça n'a pas
fonctionné donc ça c'était en vélo c'est
sûr saturés alors là le plan il à
l'envers vous l'avez vu en fait c'est
sûr saturé ici c'est pour que ce soit un
côté très flatteur on le voit aussi au
niveau des quilles à vélo ça fonctionne
voyez là comme c'est sûr ça tuerait ça
le traitement qui nous ont mis là où
autrefois fois physique montfort
regardez comme c'est saturé regarder la
couleur des faudrait que j'ai mis du
rouge à lèvres j'ai pas mis de rouge à
lèvres ok problème d'autres lumières on
l'a vu au on le voit sur le front on est
sur une caméra de celle ci un c'est pas
un truc de dingue mais c'est pas normal
ça me surprend pas moins la colo est
bizarre le choix qu'ils ont faits au
niveau de la colorimétrie est très très
très très très étrange quand même et je
trouve que ça y va quand même vachement
fort voyez tout de suite la pâte stade
ça chez moi c'est redoutable et une fois
que s'est posée ça marche mieux et c'est
pas mal à regarder pour moi ce
smartphone voyez même si on est un peu
plus de 500 euros on peut l'utiliser
pour venir faire de la création pour tik
tok même là sur un truc youtube ça
fonctionne alors on aura pas stable faut
le poser il faut le connaître il faut
savoir mais on peut faire des choses et
c'est pas mal franchement sur sa pas mal
du tout à la main c'est noël noël noé
noël rigueur mais c'est pas mal on va
pas trop mais ça sert à rien mais c'est
franchement pas mauvais et alors si on
vient chercher un peu plus loin dans la
nuit voyez la nuit je trouve qu'en fait
ce petit flash qu'on a il doit pas
servir la nuit parce qu'à pas venir
filmer la nuit les capteurs ils ont
besoin de lumière c'est pas optimisé
sais pas c'est pas ou c'est pas beau
mais dès que vous avez un tout petit peu
moins de lumière en intérieur ou sur un
petit contre jour ça fait un petit
renfort et c'est pas mal le fait d'avoir
un flash led de chaque côté ça vient de
dessiner ça c'est un truc assez joli son
visage est ce que ça pas mal donc pour
moi ce smartphone pour moi il
intéressant pour rien vous loguez si
vous avez de la lumière bien évidemment
on n'est pas sur un truc de dingue mais
très honnêtement et par rapport à ce
qu'on connaît sur l'ensemble du marché
alors c'était pas un comparatif hyper
exhaustif mais par rapport à plein de
choses que j'ai pu voir et ben je trouve
que pour à peine un peu plus de 500
euros il s'en sort bien et on arrive à
faire des choses sympas on peut venir
bloguer attention on le pose sur un pied
on va pas le tenir à la main ou alors on
est super stabiliser très fort est ce
qui n'est pas mon cas mais globalement
vivo a sorti un truc pas mal alors après
on n'est pas sur le smart le plus fou
fou du monde c'est pour ça que je
prononce sur le prisme du côté bloc
parce que déjà c'est la grosse promesse
qui est fait ici par vivo et puis le
reste c'est une fiche technique qui est
pas mal mais un peu moyenne et au final
je trouve un peu cher un peu moins de
500 euros ça me semblerait pas mal on a
quand même un grand écran 6 5044 pousser
ça flashe des plus symboliques autre
manière c'est pas mal on peut venir
jouer avec la performance fondées chez
mediatek d'inner city 920 bon pourquoi
pas on a 12 il ya drame plus de la ram
virtuel pour venir apporter je dirais si
sur ce que vous avez plein
d'applications garde ça pourra venir
aider un peu ça c'est pas mal la
recharge rapide 44 soit pourquoi pas
pour moi c'est une fiche technique qui
est assez sérieuse qui est pas mal je le
voudrais un peu moins cher et surtout de
trouver surtout intéressant dans cette
couleur là parce qu'il avait coûté sympa
et lorsqu'il vient changer de couleur au
soleil voilà c'est assez marrant donc
c'est pas mal c'est marrant de voir que
vivo vient de prendre un jeu par un
contre-pied les choses un peu
différemment et pour un coût voilà c'est
intéressant je passe à peu vous bottez
vaut un smartphone ce que vous êtes
créateur de contenu est ce que vous vous
loguez est-ce que c'est quelque chose
qui pourrait vous bottez disent le moins
aux commentaires il n'est pas parfait
loin de là mais il est intéressant on
continuera regarder ce que fait vivre
parce que font de jolies promesses
episol surtout même si aujourd'hui en
france il reste quand même de grands
inconnus mais bon il travaille à se
faire connaître et ça c'est intéressant
je vous embrasse prenez soin de vous et
à très vite